qué tal buenas tardes es un placer estar
aquí en este evento de texto web el día
de hoy les voy a platicar acerca de la
importancia del entorno que es clave
están parte fundamental para la
formación de líderes desgraciadamente
nada nos enfocamos en las partes
técnicas de cómo promueve el liderazgo
pero yo siento que una parte muy
importante es el entorno en que nos
desenvolvemos ya sea el entorno
educativo el entorno empresarial el
entorno familiar entonces para que me
entiendas la relación que hay entre el
entorno y la forma de ser de uno les voy
a poner un ejemplo este es un proyecto
que tuve placer de visitar que se llama
biosfera número dos porque phusion
biosfera número dos porque decían que la
biosfera número uno es el mundo en el
que vivimos actualmente pues me decía
estos investigadores decían que la
biosfera 2 básicamente era hacer domos
gigantescos como los ven en la pantalla
cada domo tenía un clima en especial el
clima de la alta montaña el clima
tropical el clima del desierto o en fin
lo que quieran hacer estos científicos
es ver la interacción
que hay entre estos climas para de
alguna manera llevar estos domos y
llevarlos a otro planeta y que nosotros
los seres humanos podamos recrear la
forma en la que estamos viviendo
actualmente claro que si la pandemia lo
que detectaron sus científicos desde que
veían crecer el árbol
crecí a los 345 años como que se doblaba
caí al piso y falleció decían qué está
pasando pues le agregaron más minerales
vitaminas fertilizantes mismo proceso
ahora crecía más rápido el árbol pero al
segundo tercer año como que se doblaba
caí al piso y falleció después de
cientos de millones de dólares de
inversión en este proyecto la conclusión
de este proyecto de la biosfera 2 fue
ésta que estos domos no podían recrear
las adversidades del clima o sea no
podían recrear los huracanes las
tormentas granizadas heladas incendios
entonces estos árboles crecían en esta
burbuja sin ningún tipo de adversidades
y esto es una parte muy importante para
que nosotros como seres humanos podamos
de alguna manera desarrollar este
liderazgo por ejemplo hay una frase que
me gusta mucho
japonesa que se curó vacante de mochila
saint croix significa este sentimiento
de dificultad
sufrimiento adversidades acá te viene
del verbo cow que es compra y de
mochilas hay es hasta hay que hacerlo
bajo la filosofía japonesa el tener
adversidades en tu vida personal son tan
importantes para el crecimiento que
hasta hay que comprarlos sí porque si no
tú no maduras como ser humano
entonces debido a este tema de que las
adversidades nos ayudan a crecer les
quiero comentar ahora que estamos en
plena pandemia que las crisis en japón
tiene una connotación propositiva no
tiene una connotación negativa como aquí
en latinoamérica
crisis se escribe que se dice que está
escrito por estos dos caracteres el
primer que el rojo que es de quique en
que es peligro y el segundo aquí el azul
que es de chica y que es oportunidad
bajo la filosofía japonesa una época de
chiki es una época propositiva porque
porque haces un alto en lo que tienes
que hacer por el gran peligro que hay
como lo hicimos ahorita con la pandemia
ve si analizas y reflexiones que hiciste
mal que existe bien y luego por la misma
desesperación te vuelves muy creativo
muy ingenioso y buscas nuevas
oportunidades que anteriormente es de
estar desde crisis de stack y que nunca
puedes haber pensado y por ende es una
época propositiva
ahora este en este mensaje de la
importancia de las adversidades se
refleja en toda la estructura japonesa
de formación empecemos con la parte
educativa por ejemplo todo mundo no sé
si están viendo cobra calle quién
netflix al tanque está muy de moda en
ciencia y sensei ciencia que es el
maestro vamos a analizar qué significa
sense son dos caracteres ching shelby de
carácter chino que es en qué es llegar
al tercer primero adelantarse y el
segundo carácter chino que sea que es un
marero que viene del verbo nacer
básicamente las personas que nacieron
antes que nosotros al tener mayor
experiencia mayores de antigüedad
etcétera etcétera etcétera son los que
nos enseñan a nosotros a ser mejores
personas por eso el sensei
ahora este tema de sensei cómo es que
viene aplicado a las escuelas los niños
hay un concepto la estructura muy bonita
que se conoce como sempai coja y al
igual que el sensei y el 1er
carácter chino de sen es adelantarse y
primero llegar primero del centro y
sempai del paine o el high es de un
grupo entonces sempai es aquella persona
que entró antes a un grupo y coyhaique
scott a todo después es la persona que
entró después del grupo dos y un niño de
kinder entra por primera vez al kinder
él es él coja y de todos los que están
23 arriba
años arriba del que sea uno sempai ellos
les enseñan al coja y qué hacer al igual
que en la primaria los de 1º 2º de
primaria pues tienen sus empire que son
los de 3º 4º 5º 6º de primaria y la
belleza de esta estructura es de que a
través de esta estructura que es en todo
japón les enseñan a los niños cómo
formarlos no son los maestros los que
forman a los niños los maestros observan
y orientan y guían a los niños para ser
buenos modelos si por ejemplo aquí vemos
unas fotos en la cual
escuelas japonesas hacen ellos virus de
limpieza los sempai los de arriba son
aquellos que enseñan a los cojan a los
de abajo a cómo limpiar el baño cómo
limpiar el salón cómo limpiar todo
inclusive a la hora de la comida los
empaques son los que dan la comida si
ofrecen la comida y enseñan a la gente
de abajo cómo servir mejor la comida de
manera higiénica cómo lavar los platos
cómo lavar la cocina etcétera etcétera
etcétera inclusive cuando van
a la escuela sí es muy interesante
porque se forman grupos y comentarán
aquí en esta foto la gente que es
siempre la gente más adulta más los
niños que son más adultos orientan a los
niños y los llevan y los cuida entonces
este sistema es muy importante porque de
manera estructurada
los niños de mayor rango o mayor
antigüedad enseñan como modelos y esto
también se ve reflejado en las empresas
yo trabajé para una empresa japonés
entonces curiosamente en ese entonces no
había internet pero como dato cultural
les digo que las empresas japonesas
contratan de por vida de por vida es
como adaptar un hijo o sea ibas a pasar
toda tu vida profesional para la misma
empresa o sea tienes que hacer una
tontería tener una mega tontería para
que te core entonces yo sin saber esto
decidí trabajar a japón porque me
interesaba mucho aprender acerca de
cultura laboral japonesa y curiosamente
siendo graduado de la universidad de
california en berkeley que en ese
entonces era la mejor tercera revisada
del mundo la cual tiene más de 110
ganadores del premio nobel hablando
perfectamente de tres idiomas
me acuerdo que llegué a esta empresa y
dije voy a hacer el gerente más joven en
la historia de esta empresa para que
vean quién es alejando el caso ganó
y curiosamente me decían sabes que
alejandro puso antes de ser gerente
antes de correr pues tienes que aprender
a caminar y antes de caminar tienes que
emprender a gatear porque eres un recién
nacido sad acabamos de adoptar como un
empleado que acaba de iniciar su carrera
profesional en esta empresa entonces
pues vas a empezar desde abajo elige
poussin pues está bien no me importa
curiosamente la empresa en la que
trabaja es una empresa que se destaca
porque vende unos botecitos con
lactobacilos de casa por casa allá en
japón dije bueno pues voy a empezar a
vender de casa en casa pero curiosamente
no solamente fue una semana no solamente
no solamente fue en tres meses seis
meses fueron tres largos años en los que
estoy vendiendo de casa en casa éstos
frasquitos tres largos años pues
imagínense miedo de ser un graduado de
berlín la tercer mejor universidad del
mundo en ese entonces hablando
perfectamente bien y tres idiomas que
esté vendiendo tanto tiempo de casa en
casa yo me acuerdo que iba
a las reuniones de ex alumnos de
broadway en tokio ya sabes no todo mundo
estaba presumiendo de lo que hacía que
si banqueros y financieros consultores
etcétera etcétera y me decían alejando
tú qué haces no pues yo vendo estos
asuntos de casa en casa y si en que se
hace es la estrategia mercadológica esto
no no no
literal voy apretó el timbre espero que
salga el señor a la señora y hago mi
proceso de venta y déjeme decirles que
en invierno en menos 20 21 grados bajo
cero en la nieve jalando tu carrito es
algo muy muy duro fue la adversidad
profesional más fuerte que tú es el
tsunami de mi vida profesional pero ahí
aprendí tres cosas muy importantes
obviamente en esos tres años o de ese
proceso pero te estoy eternamente
agradecido de ese proceso que me ayudó a
crecer como árbol fortalecer mis raíces
porque porque lo que entendí primero es
de que el título universitario no
importa mucho sea el título a ver si
está no es un boleto de entrada para
entrar a las empresas a trabajar
obviamente si el bonito
dice universidad de harvard pues se te
abren todas las puertas de todas las
empresas del mundo
porque una vez que entras en la empresa
mucho depende de ti que tanto esfuerzo
le echas que tanto auto desarrollo que
tanto estudias que tanto te preparas
para poder salir adelante porque yo
tenía colegas que no tienen un título
universitario y vendían más que yo decía
cómo es posible que estas personas que
no han tenido en la ciencia tura de nada
más que yo no ese coraje es lo que me
enseñó esta experiencia la segunda
experiencia es la resiliencia imagínense
tocar 100 casas y que de esas 100 casas
damas te abra la puerta a 30 y que seas
30 personas que te abrieron la casa
solamente dos o tres te compren el
producto entonces esto de lunes a
viernes esto durante tres años me ayudó
a ser súper reciente o sea no me da
miedo el que me digan que no no me dan y
me aviento y me echo mi speech y ya
después de esa época de fortalecer tanto
mi raíz me siento muy seguro de poder
vender lo que sea y el tercer punto muy
importante
es este tema de liderazgo ejemplar y
obviamente yo al entrar el primer año la
empresa era un coja y era el de menor
nivel y el cenpat que estaba 12 años
arriba de mí me enseñó todas las
técnicas de venta pero yo también estaba
seguro que el próximo año yo iba a ser
sempai o sea yo ten de igual tengo la
obligación de capacitar a los que entran
abajo de mí entonces el capacitar una
persona que llega abajo de ti es una
gran gran responsabilidad tienes que ser
el modelo a seguir el modelo así y
modelo en japón se escribe tejón el
primer carácter chino este que es malo y
el segundo carácter hong que es libre o
sea tú en carne propia
tienes que enseñarle a la gente de abajo
todos sus conocimientos todos los
valores ética todo para que para que
éste coja y pueda crecer en toda la
empresa es una estructura muy muy
interesante
y esto obviamente me ayudó mucho aquí
cuando regrese aquí a mexico a dirigir
varias empresas en la cual la anterior
empresa en la cual dirigía al seamos una
carrera de 5 kilómetros y si yo digo hay
que ponerse la camiseta pues yo como el
director general me la pongo y me la
pongo más que los demás
los fijes en estas fotos y en esta
persona con la botarga haciendo el
saludo de la bandera corriendo los 5
kilómetros y sí
el de la botarga soy yo
el director general
de la empresa que ya no trabajo para la
empresa ahorita otras cosas pero quiero
que entiendan que el liderazgo ejemplar
es una pieza clave y que si va a haber
muchas adversidades que van a afrontar
ustedes jóvenes todos los demás pero es
clave para el desarrollo profesional y
personal no solamente de ustedes sino
todos los cojan toda la gente que está a
su cargo
esta estructura en japon sería
obviamente les dije desde las escuelas a
las empresas ha sido yo siento que es la
clave del éxito de las empresas
japonesas curiosamente mi mentor
académico al profesor hirotaka takeuchi
de la universidad de harvard el harvard
business school me decía que de las
empresas más antiguas que me tiene más
de 300 años
un 40% de esas empresas son empresas
japonesas
porque si hay empresas como toralla que
está acá que se panes y dulces y demás o
te quedas ella que hace medicinas y
demás y fíjense tú eres son 17
generaciones que llevan la
administración de la empresa porque
tanto porque el hijo del dueño empieza
desde abajo
si los hijos de los sueños empiezan
desde abajo al igual que todos tienen
que limpiar los baños tienen que limpiar
las oficinas tienen que hacerla de
cajeros tienen que hacer los pasteles
los dulces o sea aprenden de todo desde
abajo y como los demás colaboradores ven
que el hijo del dueño también hace lo
mismo que ellos
ellos tienen una autoridad moral que
nadie se las puede quitar y es por eso
que toda la gente sigue a todos estos
hijos estos de estas empresas
ahora aquí en méxico qué está pasando en
la cima que está pasando
desgraciadamente no estamos formando
líderes estamos sobre protegiendo a
nuestros hijos a los futuros líderes de
la sociedad nos estamos sobre
protegiendo yo entiendo porque la
seguridad está muy muy caótica si los
tendemos a proteger pero quiero que
entiendan de que si los sobre protegemos
estos niños estos jóvenes nunca van a
ser líderes ejemplares porque no va a
tener esta fuerza de resiliencia
yo conozco muchísimos empresarios
muchísimos empresarios que sus hijos son
ni ni ni ni ni ni ni estudian ni
trabajan ni buscan empleo animaros a
dallas el papá necesito y el papá le da
en abundancia sí y esa es la
problemática que tenemos actualmente en
nuestro querido méxico y latinoamérica
nos estamos enfocando demasiado sobre
protegerlos y no entendemos que esa
sobreprotección está causando que este
país cada vez se vaya
hacia atrás entonces cuál es la solución
la solución muy sencilla volver a las
bases
este carácter chino se conoce como hoy a
hoy es padre o madre de familia y está
compuesto por tres caracteres el primer
carácter verde que es que es árbol que
parece un árbol el segundo carácter que
está en círculo azul que está a su que
separarse y el tercer carácter del lado
derecho que es miró que es ver
esto es la función de un buen padre un
buen líder estar arriba del árbol
observando a los hijos a que se den sus
trancas o sus golpes sufran tengan sus
adversidades sepan que los errores
tienen consecuencias y como padre como
líder orientados orienta si no llevamos
a cabo esto nosotros los jefes y también
los padres o madres de familia lo único
que estamos haciendo es formar como en
la biosfera dos estos árboles
un bosque lleno de estos árboles que con
cualquier adversidad se van a doblar y
van a desaparecer muchas gracias